yeah there are cheap flights to London
from like different major cities in the
u.s. I've seen flights from New York to
London for like $99
yeah Chicago to London I think the
lowest it goes is like 150 the the key
is to be flexible with dates and to
track prices because I they fluctuate
uh-oh is there audio issues again can
move them like further away it could be
the cord and it's gone again okay
I have to check that out I may need a
new cable or something okay so this is
what's renowned Rhys let's play let's
play this play Knight GE - it's a slower
move just playing a6
that's why a4 crush his dreams of ever
playing b5 and the goal is to just do
this and then decide ok never mind this
is where d4 is necessary to give back an
isolated pawn I guess d4 is possible
here I think g3 I'll admit I'm out of
any sort of preparation but I know ideas
eventually white just wants to get some
better structure me OTT I get my flights
usually I check prices on Google flights
and then it's a matter of also checking
specific Airlines also like looking for
the best ways to redeem like miles or
credit card points so there's a few
different strategies
last year I got a one-way from Chicago
to Australia for $340 was one stop in
Shanghai but it was amazing flight like
the flight was half empty Niels provided
for breakfast lunch and dinner
it was great oh let's take let's just
play positionally
I will play Bishop here but I'm not sure
about 94 and I take c6
I take c3 Knight 68 we trade everything
I went d5 and I think it's okay and this
is a tactical threat it could get messy
but this I think I'm okay with 92 92
Bishop g4 I might have to play f3 at
some points
there's also King f1 let's play 92 yeah
the the one issue is [ __ ] one ways is
sometimes getting back that's why every
three months it's nice to get a new
credit card I get the sign up bonus yeah
this is a bit uncomfortable be Bishop f3
and then there's Bishop h3 and there's
Queen h4 I just want a castle
if you have a hundred thousand miles you
should come to London it's good a good
time to use them
I think I might be able to castle next
move if I can castle play 94 I'll be
happy
I've never had a problem with customs
like having a one-way usually I book if
I go to some foreign place I'll book the
fight out of there and then there
they're okay with it
they don't always ask if I'm like where
I'm going next they just ask how long
you're staying
okay he's taking his time trying to
figure out it's a nice thing about
positions like this is uh in fact that
sometimes the pressure is on black tax
she creates something while white just
wants to castle and have a good time
yeah some people were saying Bishop III
would have been a better move
although mod is not fond of that move
but now okay I have ideas now of this
and this this I'll start with 94 nothing
I want to take play this mmm
our queen f4 let's just do this this is
one of like one of these ideal positions
to have in a blitz game where just want
to keep the time advantage and treat it
as kind of a long grind and of course
not plunder I'm gonna play rookie one
because now there's a pin probably
threatening f3
are there still audio issues what's
going on with the audio I don't know if
I have another chord
I can check okay now he has a gun I
wonder if people are getting different
sounds depending on whether or not like
you're using headphones sometimes that
happens
can I just play 9 f3 now let's play
Queen d2 be solid if I can take and
trade more the one advantage to having
the iqp is that there's a little bit
more space but usually the more trades
the happier I am
yeah I think after I end this dream off
I'll test the audio issues to make sure
that we're trying to figure out the
issue I would like to trade Queen's
Queen g5 or maybe I'll just go back to
d4 mmm
let's whoa 8:4 is hanging its y94 this
is a three hour long tournament
leader already has six points I think
I'll put the Queen on d1 it's kind of an
annoying move though okay let's play
this if H three kings you won just have
to stay controlled okay this is a threat
I want to play King f1 soon I really
won't playing Knight g5 then lucky one
check so let's play King f1 and now I
would like to trade Queens probably with
this move he can win a forward with oh I
win h3
after you make any sense that's why f3
it looks scary but I'm not too scared
each three is gonna fall
now that four will come
yeah it was kind of a matter of being
patients that's a long game though you
almost went the full 10 minutes okay
good game never play f3 well too late so
I'm in I'm in the top 42 points
95 work there is one point I wanted to
play Knight g5 but it didn't quite work
let's bezerk and let's play no I want to
play someone wanted to play the English
earlier I'll play an English they were
asking for English tactics b5 um let's
play g3 I'm gonna play like a reversed
Sicilian type line or I just kind of
expand he's doing the same thing I did
to my last opponent okay I should move
quickly so I don't want to spend too
much time in the opening so I'll go for
this in this
if eight three and a five weren't
included then d5 would be a move
interesting line okay let's play d4
and I'm gonna be patient I just want to
play quick moves and play restrictively
and keep improving maybe I'll put the
knight on d5 crusher c7 even Nyepi five
could be a move like 95 combined with my
d5 massive pressure against c7 and then
it should g5 just trying to make all the
pieces happy
I'll probably get to take next and then
double the pawns and then control the
e-file but I'm not winning any material
or am I could trade c6 is coming I don't
want to trade with blacks pieces are
like this
c6 might still come the night will
return to f4
now it's mainly positional he files so
nice I'll just double up good move
okay let's invade and go for the kill
can pre move Queen h6 rook F 7 has to be
playing I think then maybe I can play
this
and if d5 I can take and maybe I can
still play I still play this I'm going
slightly crazy but I like the initiative
I like the fact that black only has less
than 45 seconds to as I'm imagining if I
pin the rook all have Queen g7 means you
can also just take the rook I also have
this move hmm Queen I fates a good move
though where's my wind yeah I don't want
to play dirty but I might have to
because I don't see the immediate win
that's unfortunate
okay took a little too long there now
it's a some two miners rooking coupons
what is going on I have rookie 7 in some
line let's play this if the light moves
I'll play rookie 7 there we go
and I would like to Queen might be
difficult though
okay
aza fights I really thought I should
have had a cleaner win but maybe maybe
Queen FA it was good defense took a lot
of time here
yeah it was probably a dubious sacrifice
maybe I should have played probably
should have started with 95 anyway a
good game I am in 18th place after two
games that was a beserk and this is more
decisive so far than the World
Championship thanks for the comments
mateesah let's play I'm in the berserk
what to extend my lean ooh
did not mean to do that but maybe it
will work out for the best
hey it's a sub Sara nilly oh thanks for
the sub so we have a line of like the
pansy honey which can't complain about
this this is funny we neither of us want
to take each other's pawns
so much tension let's just castle like
that file to open because now there's a
lot of pressure on the Knights and the
bishop can't really exploit the diagonal
maybe queen f8 just building up pressure
okay so there's a mate threat
I can do this
maybe I should get around to taking what
to do I'm feeling wanted to take on that
three let's do it
feeling aggressive maybe not the most
sound sacrifice but I just want to win
quickly and take on each three he might
trade Queens my pawn on d4 has been
there for so long but I have a lot of
pawns for the exchange with three pawns
for the exchange
let's just defend in order to develop
the knight in the rook he has to do
something about the pond looks like I'm
winning more material now well he
probably should have taken on D 498 SAS
ad move but it does defend I think next
I want to play a 390 for a six maybe
pawn g49 should redevelop at some point
okay so black is up three pawns down a
little bit of time what other games do I
play used to play a lot of Poker
I like Scrabble like tennis ping pong
bowling soccer play a lot of games luck
house saga cage six coming okay uh GG on
the verge of breaking twenty four twenty
three hundred not quite close to twenty
four hundred yeah there's a lot of chess
players who play ping-pong
when I went to college our chess team
got two ping-pong tables we start
playing more ping-pong than actual chess
okay so I'm top ten five points behind
the leader I can't say that I have a
favorite color depends on the scenario
okay I'm playing Cara in 1966 umm how
good at tennis am I
I'm better than averagely I'm better
than average person but I'm not like I'm
not that's serious
but I played in high school I played
second singles my varsity team for four
four years but recently I haven't played
much hey I broke 2,300 okay let's bezerk
the sky and Okara 1966 was in first
place
now it's paused in the tournament let's
take on d5 and play d4 similar idea to
that other game I had in whatever it's
Sicilian variation black will have an IQ
P maybe Queenie to check can I win a
pawn can win upon looks like a free pawn
later I'll play like Bishop III great
now there's still a threat let's take
maybe I can play b4 I'm being very
greedy
I could be punished for this
v6 is a good move but I'm still up upon
oh this is coming oh this could be
really bad this guy's only 1,500 this is
really bad and I buzzards
I really have to fight
yeah this is a punishment for being
overly greedy thankfully black did not
play 94 which would have just won a
piece now at least this is playable it
might actually just be equal here
we both have isolated pawns well let's
put the rock on do you want
and time management is important
and the goal is still to exploit this
pawn probably c4 it's pinned and
attacked twice Lock probably has to
defend it one of these night moves I can
take and keep adding pressure hey it's a
sub Duran Springer
thanks for the sub and keeps rolling
finally catching a stream yeah I must
try and stream more at least on the off
days of the World Championship so
probably every third day I'll have a
stream if you guys are lucky maybe I'll
stream in the evening if there's a short
game okay so what could have been a
really disastrous game is now seeming to
go in a better direction there's a bunch
of discoveries but I don't think there's
anything too strong bumblebee zero zero
one two I gave my thoughts in the video
earlier in the stream I think it's it's
being out it's being made out to seem
like a much bigger deal than it actually
is of course it wasn't the most ideal
thing for for like Fabiano to have
released in the public but whatever like
whatever the openings that were kind of
shown in the video for the whatever
freeze frame they weren't the biggest
surprises like there were maybe a few
ideas but as long as uh the meat of the
preparations isn't shared I don't think
it's a huge deal
it was actually a really well produced
video - it's kind of sad that it's
getting all this negativity surrounding
it but the video it was it felt like a
movie I really like a documentary style
like cinematic type filmmaking okay so I
have a passed pawn that's defended a
bunch of times
98 might be played but then I have
ripped d5 let's attack the Queen the
Queen has like one square maybe I could
trap the Queen like rookie 5 Queen g6
let me move then h4 Queen h6 9f5 that's
just about trapping the Queen
because 97 will happen 97 will be a fork
or a discovery that's nice I think these
are the only safe Queen moves that's a
free queen it's not entirely free
feels pretty free pass 199 less ugh lots
of people have 99 next to their name no
idea why that is I think this is force
mate oh it's definitely Force mates okay
good game yeah 94 like early on I was
way over ambitious rookie it was a good
move
I should have castled sooner I should
not take on v6 maybe Queen b5 was a move
anyway doctor tournament I'm in first
place over 2300 not sure how life could
get any better playing the guy in sixth
place I can't play the Stafford gambit
against e4 but I can play the anti
London
okay so this is a playable move order ID
you have 92 is it kind of discourages
Queen b6
let's take I'm gonna play the Wesley so
variation this is a nice nice tricky
line 9 h5 followed by Bishop d6 thanks
for the bits Sarah Nelly oh and now I'll
probably get the bishop pair pass 199
this is one of the best lines this is
one of those lines that if white plays
the right move order then it makes sense
to go into if you can't play the Queen
b6 line this is kind of the backup line
seems like this guy has some clue what
he's doing let's start with g6 put the
bishop back here
and the goal from this position is just
to be patient and hold on to the bishop
pair and someday when the position opens
up maybe the bishops will be impressive
but so far he's playing well I feel a
little bit it's a little bit
claustrophobic okay we're gonna have to
trade the rook here go for some minority
attack I might even go for the trade now
that my bishop is just garbage on on g7
I have to be careful though of f5 it's
an idea I don't think it's playable it's
just she takes off five
we actually just have a kind of a French
structure usually French structures are
pleasant if there's a lot off the board
because then I can just focus on
positional play that's expecting
politics it's also playable maybe B 5b
5a 5b four also maybe preparing this
yeah that's a scary-looking move
actually I'm type of move that makes me
want to trade even further let's go for
this probably getting ready to trade at
least a pair of rooks that gives me a
bit more comfort
let's play this now if this I could
consider taking with the e pawn because
the Queen asked some supports before
still an idea and before might be the
threat could prepare it with a five
do I need to just be four right away
wait then he just takes mmm let's play
five
I mean this is what I want the situation
to be I want the situated be on the
Queen side and not on the Kings side I
feel like I'm kind of achieving that
okay that makes me happy
rook t4 probably expected then we can
get some Queen ending I still want to
play b4 now is probably the time they're
trying to induce some weakness
have some alignments and pressure in
multiple directions probably take with
the Queen
so I have a passed pawn he has a queen
side majority it's going to be a fight
this looks attractive
just fighting for squares around the
light King me King age 7 soon try and
put the King on g6 trading Queens might
lead to a winning King pawn ending
depending and depending where my king is
it's interesting move I think I can play
this ah
that was probably a bad move or was it I
probably was he doesn't take it ok now I
have this I'll win h2 and maybe even a 2
I take on eight - it gets scary
kingi sevens interesting trying to
calculate the King pawn ending I think
it's winning like okay I'll start with
Queen g3 we trade King g6 King f3 king
of five King III King g4 King d4 he
takes King their King III King Jiggs
before d4 a 4d 3a 52 a6 yeah so I'm
winning by one tempo thing else to
calculates I don't think so
for him I have one pawn fixing two pawns
oh maybe he could try and get opposition
somehow but it's not going to work as
all of d4
this should be even easier win
okay maybe I'll just do this actually
let's just do this okay
on passant is important for these types
of situations okay interesting game yeah
today is a rest day I rested a lot I'm
still tired still kind of overcoming
jetlag
who's winning it's more like who's
drawing between Carlson cargo Lana yeah
no one's winning quite yet let's go back
to tournaments let me ask you guys let's
do a poll know how many people are
watching but um how many of you are not
actively following the world
championship but just enjoy chess and
just watch twitch and play online
is there anyone who's like not actively
following the games let's play a London
I'm in London I forgot to play this
opening more consistently
so I feel like the the world
championship games they're really
interesting if you kind of understand
the theory and preparation that goes
into the games but just kind of being a
mere spectator maybe not the most
exciting event it's actually one of my
jobs to make it exciting and find like
interesting angles as I'm doing
basically doing an extended social media
take over for us chess is this guy
playing the same line I guess it's
different because he can't play Knight
h5 wait why is my bishop on g3 oh I was
just assuming he was gonna play Bishop
d6 I still confused why my bishop got to
g3 okay it's not the worst of things
that can happen
actually positions like this are really
pleasant because usually it just leads
to an easy attack for whites let's start
with this move usually early ideas of
this and this and this well one of the
reasons why I'm delaying castings if
Knight takes g3 I want my work on each
one so what's fine 95 maybe things will
open up
you can take with pawn get a knight to
d4 it's not that easy to actually break
through or is it queen g4 f5 let's go
for the slide I'm threatening rook takes
h6 if f5 I have Queen g6 King h8 might
be flexible that maybe I Castle
queenside get both rooks into action Jay
King H a castling queenside I think the
threat would be rook takes h6 now the
problem is I'm threatening riff takes h6
he plays King H and I probably still
take I still want to take but probably
doesn't work anymore
Queenie aids i completely forgot about
can get away with rook takes h6 now the
problem is he trades and plays King h7
my rook is trapped so I have to take
okay it's gonna be positional thanks for
the sub super a major pain turn off the
speakers things are turned off I don't
know what's going on with them like like
it's sporadic and some people just don't
hear it
I could unplug my mic we unplug and
fiddle around
that's weird it's only affecting some
people ok the sound should be hopefully
better play a four
for those of you who are hearing though
whatever high-pitched sound are you
wearing headphones are you are you not
wearing headphones it's a first step
into troubleshooting you wants to play
on the kingside so each form might be an
idea I'll play f3
just to make Ben Feingold upsets because
if he plays h4 I can play g4
you can trade and then I have some a
file action my double pawns are in two
week or maybe they are
[Music]
what to do maybe this just gain more
space
I want to open the file let's put their
work on anyone I have a feeling that
could have to do with like my phone you
put my phone in airplane mode there
won't be any uh whatever interference
signals yeah I'm not actually sure where
my pieces should go feels a bit awkward
my nights might be happier on the square
you be my king should be on b2 erik has
to go to you too
I have to move quicker
okay that makes me happy or does it
let's put the knight back I have some
defense
Rikka for is coming
okay this feels wrong but my pawns are
defended by the knight
I would love to get my knight to f6
that's an interesting move
maybe Knight g1 things are about to get
really weird the pawns on h2 I don't
know if it's weak or it's strong it's
both weakened strong
I want my rook to come to a fauna UBA
push a day for check
yeah there's gonna be a lot of moving
around
might come down to the trying to flag
him but the king on e - probably
oh there's Bishop f4 but then like when
h2p takes on g5 or not every way
Oh G - hangs it's not good this is still
okay or not
I gotta move quicker this is looking
really bad I think I have a threat of
this defending attacking no clue what's
going on now
but I might be better I have to take hey
thanks for the sub wait that was a
donation I'll look at it afterwards I
don't think that was a sub okay I just
have to move quickly let's do this
I bought the exchange but this is much
worse for whites but I'm gonna win
because he's gonna flag yeah I feel
dirty final position is really good for
black but that's life
Wow are Beasley 1969
thanks for the $20 biggest donation of
the stream larger donation and I have
the free pieces my opponents have given
me back to tournaments I'm not in first
place as people have been catching up
there's two more hours left and ten
minutes
seems like there's a lot of people
watching live who normally watch on
YouTube and it's just a chance of
whether they catch me live I'm a team
Fabi but I mean I've brooded for Magnus
many times in the past but I have to
root for Fabi okay let's play against
English with Luke SIA in the chat so I'm
gonna play the same line that nine up to
three you can play this feels like I
might be overextending but I know this
looks fun I'll be night g2o f5 was
hanging I forgot that five was hanging
some fortunates now I have to treat this
like a gambit
that's so unfortunate
it's terrible maybe g6 lease got some
space and development playing an I am
from Germany okay
only down upon could be worse it's just
a terrible start to the game though yeah
my dark scores are gonna be weak but
what to do
to live with the consequences
maybe all in c4
she reminds me of the Budapest there's
some lines in the Budapest where blacks
acts upon to open that file Lucas with a
sub so much generosity I feel like when
people are generous to me it makes me
generous to my opponents which is not a
good thing there should be six he takes
this is difficult between g7 getting out
of the pin yeah the strategy in these
positions it's mainly just a couple of
losses and try and keep the game long
and complicated one hundred bits from
Lucas been paid to distract distract me
by my opponent um sounds slightly
realistic see fives a very strong move I
have a trick though there's one tactical
shot in the position I don't know if
it's gonna work at all
there's a really cool move I want to
play
ah this is bad maybe just h6 looks
reasonable do you just plunder his queen
this was my whole idea is to like win
the Queen that's happening he just
resides I was not expecting to win that
game after 16 moves especially given
what happened in the opening yeah Lucas
my opponent would have had to pay you
much more it's to distract me yeah this
is why like when you're in a better
position tactics are still important
because originally I wanted to make some
move like like Knight g4 work I thought
the threat would be too obvious
the h6 was kind of disguised as it's
going with the flow
Cretaceous Knights
thanks for the sub so back to
tournaments back in first place actually
tied for first place yeah that was not
really a gambit I guess you can call it
again of it cuz I won that's much more
of a blunder I'm gonna play another
London
okay we'll have I'll have a berry attack
or whatever this is called
it's off online seems like he kind of
knows what he's doing super major pain
with bits probably think that one I have
to win more games like that
a little bit conflicted no play Queen up
three there's some set up to play like
92 in C 3 and then Queen G 3 this is one
of the things I think I taught in my
London course like some harmonious set
up for lights but now I'm kind of
forgetting maybe I can play Bishop g5 I
have a tactical threats you can't take
on e5 also have ideas of g4 in certain
situations like g4 here looks powerful
because why not like the queen is tied
down to the night and I can't move cuz
pinned if he takes on g4 then I can take
with my Knights
now Knight bt7 is forced
kind of like to play H 5 H 5 castle this
is such a good position for white
because everything is tied down for a
black it's just a matter of showing some
decent technique which is castle
very soon h5 Volcom maybe h5 h6 h7 if G
takes h5 rook takes h5 c5 was kind of
expected I don't think it does too much
if the H file opens life will be very
good okay let's take back
yeah this is what I was thinking of
before the bishop has to move to eight
shades after age seven King g7 has to be
played and then Bishop h6 and it would
be over okay
good game
so I'm in first place of 35 points
keeping it clean trying to keep it clean
I was close to losing at least one game
maybe two games or is that one game
against the 1500 and blundered a piece
but he didn't punish me so let's play
let's play another London I'm liking
this this opening and the city I don't
know if I'm gonna play the full
tournament but it feels like I have to
give in that I'm in the lead but there's
two hours left I'm only 33% through okay
so this is a classic line always play
king b1 always play f3 he's being
aggressive g4 might be playable
usually the idea is to put the nine on
c1 just hold things together guess it's
okay to trade bishops not sure who that
benefits its my bishop usually or at
least my LightSquared Bishop doesn't
really do anything in these lines c5 is
interesting wondering if I can play e5
at the right moment or maybe even just
take on a6 play Bishop h6 trade a bit
wait there's some interesting lines I
can take on e5 take on c5 and then play
e5 there's all the pressure on d6
I mean 97 takes let's go for that so the
King's in the center the the main plan
should be to open the center I could be
misjudging something you're missing
something but looks logical still have
to be cautious about this Bishop
combined with like 94 ideas so maybe I'm
taking some risk if a knight a 4 I have
something like 93 I also have queenie to
also have pawn takes you seven yes this
is a major threat
okay so block socking upon
if you like I should take and play
Bishop h6
because I really want to get rid of this
dark square bishop it's terrifying
that's probably gonna have an attack but
I'll have some attacked - is there a
stream delay it should not be more than
40 seconds but maybe if you pause in the
resume could be delayed so now I'm
thinking that h3 may be Queen III I
don't know Queen III looks normal wait
that doesn't do anything now
so my h3 takes on f3 there's good cop
with rook f1 now let's do that I don't
think this is a monster threat there's
f6 but it's some way to get some
initiative also there's ideas of rookie
one like there's to open files so I
would like to control both of them
I need tactics Knights not defended
start with this
g5 would be a weird move probably just a
bad move looks interesting no he plays
it so I assume just queen h5 and the
Knights still attacked and now g5 is
weak so this is looking nice I mean I
wait some it's probably winning some
material back Knight takes h2 I think is
overly greedy well I can just move here
and take on g5 this line first I thought
I could take on a3 take on g5 but my
rook on do you want is hanging
so it's gonna stay interesting to play
rook d5
there's a lot of pressure points that
nine on c5 nomina three pawn and g5 pawn
are seven could be a target at some
points the media threat is to take
either night and then with other knights
or just to win the g5 han so h6 well now
I can get the two knights looks nice
yeah let's take with this room whoa I
forgot about that move that's
unfortunate I have to play this that's
really unfortunate this could be my
first loss so now I'm just down the
exchange I'm down a ton of time
I took the wrong nights
still ideas of night xg5
it doesn't seem too promising though
maybe ideas of a three give the King
some lift
yeah this is really unpleasant to play
with low time
I think the Queen might be forced back
I'll try and play 9f to rearrange things
take controlling d1 I just want to play
rook e1 next guard the back rank I can
tell he's nervous like he's taking a lot
of time which is probably my one hope I
want to play brookie you want h4 rook h1
and then made along the H file or maybe
rook a5 at some point he's saving so
much time
it's probably just shaking yeah defend
I'm feeling confident it's by h4 my
Knights defend everything except this
let's defend
hey don't distract me behave yourself
wait I have to move quickly okay that's
a free Queen Blue's Clues
appreciate the bits okay yeah I was on
the verge of losing there but somehow I
won
Kiyomi H in the chat long time no see
Kiyomi how's it going yeah that was too
close for comfort
I was almost beginning to shake so
nervous yeah i blundered there I was
taking a lot of time earlier too I
should play I just missed 92 or no
because if 92 I would have won g5 yeah I
should have taken this night and then
this night that would have been better
anyway
ah back to tournaments extending the
lead wolf a hundred bits thanks wolf aim
well Cheers today a lot of people
throwing in a hundred
greets to London the one thing I don't
like about London or anywhere like in
the US for the time being gets dark
really early I think it got dark around
like four it's kind of sad
okay let's play let's play Budapest I
forgot to Mazurek I was about to be
Zurich but then I I played my first move
too soon okay so this is no longer a
gambit but this is a pleasant position I
mean the fact that I'm ahead in
development
let's play c6 typical break so yeah I
heard there's a leaf trust me that I
heard on Fiona stream but I I don't know
any information about it
is there information already posted in
order what's the story with that because
I would love to attend it would be
really cool if Carlsen showed up to the
leach s meet up cuz didn't he show up to
look at the last one like in Norway so
that would be epic
okay now I want to do this stuff
yeah I'm in London for the next like two
weeks almost exactly two more weeks
let's trade bishops and play Knight g6
yeah Carlson has already seen me us
major pain for the last couple of press
conferences I've sat like in the front
row of press to take photos so it's like
sitting right in front of them they they
certainly see me Oh what do I do
knife at for know if that does anything
let's do it looks cool
Queen d2 I could leave my knight there
maybe I'll play Bishop g4 to make things
spicy Carlson did not study town I doubt
he remembers a game that we played even
I don't think he would associate me with
with my username am i doing a found me
that file in London I don't know if I
have enough fans but if I have enough
fans that they should organize the
Meetup and I'll help you there I've been
recognized a good handful of times
though like the first day I arrived I
was trying to figure out like the street
name because the uber car was coming and
I couldn't figure out the name of the
street so I asked like some random
person and they said they didn't know
the name of the streets but they said
they watched my streams these uh these
feelings of Fame
I play each for let's do it I'll
probably have to drop never mind
forgot about night of five takes takes
yeah things got weird
maybe Bishop h5 but I will I am planning
to attend the to meetups cuz I know I
know about the V chest Meetup oh there's
a nice there's also a chestful meet up
in about five or six days which I also
don't know I need information about but
I'll probably be there as well
ok this rook is nice to guard stuff
let's do this
oh my pawn okay it's just a pawn
yeah I'm a little bit worse here
download palling now it feels like a
gambit is he gonna take on f6 probably
doesn't work for him really want to take
on c3 okay let's play b4 first now there
are some targets
yeah I realize it still takes focus like
even when playing low rated players it
still takes some energy to keep things
under control
okay so now I can take feeling a little
bit better my bishop can breathe this is
we crook C 2 is coming we choose the
targets
this bishop is kind of stuck it's me
really sad if light has to play Bishop
you too I forgot about Bishop c6 kills
the fun
play rock a7 ideas of rook a to the good
thing here I have time and I have a safe
King and I have a plan
rook b3 also a move yeah rook takes c6
was possible but there's no reason to
sack the exchange when the rooks can
activate around the bishop
that's a good move by him don't really
want to trade Brooks probably just
turtle up and wake on time
another good move let's do this
wait I don't want a blundering mate I
was a path to take couldn't be two and
blunder rook e8 that would have been
tragic let's play f6
I forgot the bishop is also defending
the rook let's play this
yeah this is where the quality just
falls apart I feel bad but what to do
never play f6 yeah I liked my position
until I didn't like my position well I'm
still in first place Gannicus Gannicus
was working every game I've gained about
40 rating points as tournaments or about
50 rating points I'm not gonna desert
maybe I'll play a Stafford gambit
or maybe I'll play Fabiano secret
preparation no I'm just kidding is a
Mike like doing stuff again I'm
wondering if there's a high-pitched
sound for everyone but only certain
people can hear it like maybe the only
the younger viewers can hear it because
your ears are just more in tune to hear
higher frequencies not sure what's going
on anyway we have a Safra gambits this
is one of the main lines in my prep
idea of this is to do this trying to
remember
yeah the line extends beyond this I
think the next move is Queen d4 so my
opponent is being overly cautious which
ironically sometimes backfires because
now I have Knight g4 knight Knight g4 I
think this is a playable line it looks
really aggressive it could this could
easily backfire against me but as long
as he's thinking it's an extreme extreme
fishing going on here
using the fishing pole trap if the H
file opens I don't have an immediate
made threats like if h6 g 4h takes g4
it's White's move but wait a minute this
is looking really good for a meeting
it's Queen e5 how is he defending
against meet wait calculates Queen d6
might be more effective 26 let's play
Queen d6 yeah well it has to be very
careful here this is a threats
a good move I'm wondering if I can get
away with taking and then going back
also taken f2 that's a crazy position
I'm not gonna take too much risk I've
already taken enough risks queen g6
maybe wasn't isn't the most challenging
move but keeps the game going and
there's ideas of somehow exploiting this
pawn
but yeah it's probably gonna require
some slow play
that's funny my night just stays on g4
so I don't think it can still be taken
yeah I really don't know what to say
with the high-pitched noise like I could
throw my phone further away it could be
a mobile thing you know it's queenside
castle
some point I would like to play f6
really likes to play Queen I for it but
then Knight f3 quite strong
let's play King V its following
principles
really testing him he's not yet called
my bluff and now maybe at 6:00 or at
5:00 bf5 and so indecisive let's play at
5:00 that's why I can't take out the Sun
cuz it's pinned if Queenie - maybe I
play Knight f6 as a pawn is still pinned
and I want to maneuver it to e4 and then
go for this idea I'm sorry do you want
me to keep up the commentary I just
wonder the piece mmm okay now I have to
flag him do I go an extended period of
time without giving commentary there
it's not I'm forgetting okay so it's
another game I should just lose but
hopefully time will play in my favor and
it's already getting interesting
this is Queen is kind of getting kicked
around but maybe not
okay let's keep Queens on the board yeah
that's good move sway this
put the rook on g4
or maybe not
let's just put yeah I'll double up I'm
okay with trade of one pair of rooks if
a 4 a 5 maybe c5 soon tack this pawn I
don't want to trade
keeping the pin
I have to go for the check
oh this could get really bad let's play
this
if I win this that's going to be very
dirty
okay I'm trying
hmm
oh I'm so sorry
this one pawn gives me the win
yeah that's life I was expecting him to
like just start pre moving just win the
pawn at least what - okay keeping my
streak 23:50 I feel bad but I would have
also felt bad if I lost that so just
feel bad no matter what situation those
persons catching up 41 points so I'm
gonna try and maybe minimize the
blunders and the dubiousness let's play
a London I'm playing the guy in second
place super major pain
it's thanks for the bits each six is
kind of weird
really wants to play e5 let's play rook
d1 treat this a bit more positionally
really wants to play e5 hmm tell you
this I'm just gonna stop you five I
think I'm okay with taking and then just
castling gave up the bishop hair but
black can't Castle because of this pawn
and meanwhile my lots of fights it's
probably a good move let's do this
c4 who would be a great square for a
knight so I might consider this type of
stuff also ideas of this in this yeah
message on messages on leech acid they
just think there's way too many to
respond to all of them at least to
respond to all of them articulately
so I do have a thing in my profile now
that if you want to like send me a
message
there's a contact form through my
websites and that's the best way to get
in touch because I have to simplify like
my inbox somehow the problem with Lee
chest there's no there's no like
organizational tools when it comes to
the inbox like I can't make group things
and folders or archive things so it's a
first world problem I take and play e5
let's do it oh then he plays d5
I don't want him to play e5
or do I let's just do this first maybe
five Bishop III g5 oh that's a good move
it's a Bishop III g4 chops and Knights
so now G for it at least I have night h4
maybe night a4
and then c4 then back to C 3 and then e5
I see for ya
because e5 will be a lot more powerful
now that I'm having some fight for this
this d5 square let's do this
GG force still kind of annoying and do
this first giving my night a place to
drop back if Queen g6 maybe nevermind
in g65 we trade everything
okay this game is heating up too much
for me to to continue looking at the
chat so give me a moment I let's play
this and then this and then this and
then fight for squares
maybe Bishop f2 later
I play f3 there's g4 so let's play Queen
d3
yeah that's annoying
I play rookie - preparing to double up
this guy is playing well
I think now it's time for f3 if g4 I
have King each one okay this is a threat
so Bishop e3
okay now I'm feeling a bit more
comfortable because my knight can come
to g4 it's still a bit worse for whites
but at least I have a plan maybe Brooke
b2 I'll start with this
Bishop d7 I have some Queen check double
on the B file
my queen can come to some square maybe
like e1 attack the pond also have this
type of idea
this is not the time to be indecisive
that's a weird move
attacking this interesting idea let's do
this do this I can fight for the a file
some interesting idea of taking on e5 at
some point I'm gonna play this I'm gonna
sack the b-pawn I have two ideas here
rook e8 and Knight takes e5 you guys
start with this and then I take on e5
next okay this is looking nice
Queen d4 Knight g4 bishop takes G for
Queen g7 is nice this also looks
playable those kings a bit awkward can
win this pawn now and this pawn - it's
going to be a time scramble nothing new
pawns are providing some shelter
be careful not to get needed
was a fun game although a weird game I
was worse for a good portion of that I
was very critical to the standings -
yeah the big turning point was this good
moment I was able to trade rooks I guess
one turning point was when I got the
Knight to g4 and then around here - okay
- and then rookie aid and they take c5
was nice okay back to tournaments 47
points I was a bit nerve-racking keeping
the lead I'm sorry I can't address all
the comments in the chat it was just too
much
my opponent died after all of those
checks I wouldn't be surprised
okay so they the games continue let's
play another London type of opening that
takes the least amount of energy to play
okay this is where Bishop g3 makes sense
he's playing some line while the people
play this I don't understand why it's as
popular as it is is maybe he wants to
play this but I'm okay playing
positional if he plays this this gives
me my QP otherwise I'll play Queen e2
and then 95 can't take on e5 can't
Castle queenside cuz Knight takes f7
it's already looking nice I have ideas
of this
and g5 is actually quite annoying for
black okay so that's reasonable yeah
well it's probably just slightly better
nothing too too special
I think one goal is to play like f4
Knight f3 maybe someday a five okay this
is looking nice
you got four or five is still in the air
and blocks minor pieces are a bit
restricted he's going to play this or
this then we'll trade or maybe we won't
trade if Bishop e5 Bishop c2
okay so he plays a six time to to play
Knights b3 back
let's play this
okay now 95 is a major idea by the b5
kind of just a decoration looks pretty
but I think it's doing too much what to
do
maybe I can take it a 94
I'll spike we not for first no slow
improvement
payday seven
okay I'll be patience being very
patience but the moves I'm playing
there's still some purpose it's in terms
of maybe having some eventual ideas he
has some idea of Knight c4 let's move
back wow yeah that's probably not a pawn
sacrifice because g2 hangs so e5 is the
weak
okay I'll put the rook here making sure
he doesn't have annoying moves like 93
the night back on d4 I'll probably play
g3 at some points to ensure my Queens
defended maybe I might want to play out
six and the diagonal could open up
honestly I'm not sure what to do I think
I'll just take the night because it's
being annoying and now it will be good
night versus less good bishop 32 he
could win e5 it does he let's play f6 if
you take so I probably take with Queen
keeping the files closed
okay now the only open files a D file so
now it makes sense to fight for it
can I have just won a free pawn I
probably could have taken on age six
that would open the H file I should have
at least considered it
okay my knight would love to get to d6
that's a hard square to get to start
with Queen e3
good move
if you plays h4 I probably take and play
Knight f3
I mean this is just a better position
let's move the quicker I'll put the rook
on d6 play Knight before
with the Queen on c5
I should throw in this move insuring
Bishop E for his mother pin and let's go
for this than this
still a bit of a fight ship d5 looks
like I can just take that I'll play a
three just for safety measures
everything is safe it's actually a good
move
let's take and play a four and probably
trade and rookie five and went off seven
I see what he's doing
okay I want to win one of these parts
requires some moving around
hmm
interesting it's windy five
interesting
yeah those are weird finish I mean the
rock ending is probably just equal that
time is a factor
all right GG played the B for gambit
line so often what does it be for gambit
line
yeah sorry it's hard to keep up with the
chats I see there's questions it's good
to see like when there's questions other
people try and answer the questions
Oh before gambit line is Evans gambit it
sounds like you also be a tween gambits
okay so my opponents are getting
stronger I think I'll play some solid
opening names oh let's play d5 I should
f4 wait knight c6 he wants a draw I mean
every game I've played so far I've won
so I don't think I want to draw maybe
I'll play Bishop back and we'll play
some kind of boring position I'm sure
that Knight d5 isn't going to annoy me
maneuver my knight to the Kings side I'm
just going for some setup
maybe some King side attack eventually
it's interesting so wants to play e4
and usually the standard response to f3
is c5 that's okay here he's gonna play
rook e8 but I wasn't sure about these
four lines maybe now we're key aides
have to watch out for tactics against my
queen looks okay and it's an IQ p
position but he's committed to f3 so
it's not too bad I don't think maybe b5
and Queen b6 maybe Mike Bishop should go
back to see it and then b7 he wants to
play Knight p3 to c5 can probably allow
it it might be three Bishop c6
let's control the C file the only open
file on the board
if you play the night c-5 maybe I just
play a five
I might be weakening yeah okay
slightly less pleasant but maybe still
playable
go leave the tension
okay let's relieve the tension Queen d6
let's do it
no actually why not
Bishop defends this pawn the rook on c4
looks slightly Pleasant
maybe the Racal like swing back to AIDS
some day my bishop will come alive
someday okay no more no more isolate
upon for me put the rook back
maybe 95 these pawns are targets if he
for I have night takes before likes III
could maybe you work your just Bishop c6
first rook d1
[Music]
good night that for looks attractive
squares Queen d2 is probably a threat
yeah that's a move
have to move quicker what to do I don't
see any breakthrough so I'll play 93 it
simplifies a little bit but make some
progress maybe four is a target it's
hard to attack we could trade Queens
trade Queens okay one bishops annoying
to defend could go crazy and play f5 I
have to play much quicker maybe this
move attack the Knights oh the Queen's
also attacks because it's unpinned that
was a good move I think
okay this is gonna get strange because I
think I have beat 2 and if rook takes b2
I have this check maker okay one comes
regardless right is this just winning
this is just winning Wow and didn't
really abruptly yeah when I played Queen
b3 I didn't calculate that like until
the end I assumed like I thought until
it be too and maybe it's just winning
because rook a one is unstoppable
he probably has to play like 93 first
and then and still the fights okay that
was nice I was close because my time was
terrible doctor tournament so Gannicus
is trying to catch up just under an hour
left I was not planning to play this
whole tournament but here I am playing
McNall let's bezerk
okay we have a super boring symmetrical
opening and just keep copying him this
is usually the plan I go for 97 to g6 I
think a 3 should only help me I don't
know the don't know too much theory here
that's reasonable at some point I would
like to play Knight f4 an attack okay so
he's trying to do the same thing I mean
that's courage Knight g3 also enable my
queen to come in if I can play Queen f6
threat might be Bishop takes h3 there's
always looming ideas of Knight f4
Wow so do I take or do I play night off
for probably not for because this night
can be used as fuel for the future like
h5h for
have to play aggressive if 92 maybe
Knight takes h3 this one upon looks like
a free pawn get rook d8 coming wait
that's a free bishop so many gifts
forget people can be generous sometimes
okay that was quick
mechanicus is trying to make a run for
it
working every game it's still a
five-point lead
has it been determined when the next me
chest titled arena will be or maybe
that'll be determined after the the
World Championship
okay I'm playing this guy again
are you play them once when I play them
I was black
this time I'm white wait no I played
them when I was white before we played
the same line - I would have mixed it up
yeah this is like the exact same line so
he's gonna play like this attempt to to
play e5 let's play rook d1 he's gonna
play Knight ft7 and I'll play Bishop e5
okay it's the same line I don't really
know too much theory here trying to
remember how I could have improved on
the previous game he's gonna play c5 at
some points
okay Ricky one is normal I think at some
point last game I played this b3 move he
six is a new move I don't understand why
a six should be played maybe he wants to
play d5 let's play well last time he
played g5 early which was reasonable
maybe I can play e5 and if d5 Knight a
four I'll try and clamp down on the
Queen side if you plays Bishop if you
plays this move
actually I don't know you wants to play
Bishop b5 night c5 looks playable
maybe Queens III first the Queen's III
looks nice attack the pawn supporting 95
ala but then Bishop f8 maybe maybe I can
take with pawn Wow
so if b3 let's play b3 the pawn on b3 is
great against tonight on b6 I'm gonna be
patient I have to play quicker moving a
bit too slowly to be Queen d2 I'll
probably go for like h4 h5 or maybe just
like g3 first even this move
like g3 kingi to work h1 could be some
plan 9 s4 is another plan enough for
each 5
maybe just night off okay never mind no
longer have that night okay so I could
take we trade a bunch of times
I went age six if he doesn't take ID
Bishop t4 or okay five IV for hmm so you
could win each for in the end but I have
to go for this yeah
wait I can I can't take the work can I
that's scary take the bishop and then
play rook III if King g7 I have Queen d4
otherwise work H three is coming pawns
are equal he has one big fat pawn
islands lie of the Queen side majority
the Queen d4 first Queen g7 we trade
stuff maybe before before let's play
before
at some point I'll play c3 and be solid
let's start with this move it's probably
gonna plate rook a three then rook at
three kick the Queen around probably
Queen d4 at some point also g3 to Kim G
to at some points
Queen I for back I probably fudgy three
he wants to take on before
just be safe
okay - Queen d4
all right maybe just queen d3
interesting
now take and play queen bee - and just
start pushing my beep on probably
problem is he is queen h6 queen h1 so I
probably have to keep attacking the rook
this could end in a draw
I feel like I'm better though maybe rook
d3 and play for a win Queen h6 rook do
you wan we'll get some Queen ending
these beings oh he keeps attacking the C
pawn it's a very strong move
oh no I'm worse cuz I turned down the
draw what a move Queen eight shades this
is bad
King f3 doesn't work King f3 does it
work
this is desperate this is really bad
this is not gonna work no I'm losing my
first game oh so sad yeah Queen eh-eh
was so strong because of Queen h6 which
is kind of what I was expecting then
rook t1 it's okay but now work do you
want I lose c3 and then his deep on runs
I probably should have gone for that
instead of king f3 what to do so it's
gonna be a neck-and-neck race it's gonna
kiss she's on a streak and I'm not okay
it's berserk
I probably just should have taken the
draw vacuum so we have someone on Team
scandi I don't know what to play against
this opening such a dumb opening just
want to be aggressive g4 let's play g4
maybe if Bishop g 6f for just go for the
kill
okay this sorry it looks like some
success because e 6 is hard to play a 95
is coming
okay let's put the knight on e4 and
check meet him okay
I was great it's really nice
neither the game like that after your
that previous one I know I am playing
this guy else oh let's not resign what's
Boozer and let's go for this stuff did I
have bishop takes f7 maybe I did
Oh Bishop takes us often followed by 96
I guess that would have also worked okay
so he's playing the Stafford whatever
I'm playing the Stafford gambit but it's
not really gambit
because he gave me back the pawn for
free so now it's just a nice position
I'll probably go for Bishop f5 in rookie
Yeates maybe I don't know you should g4
or Bishop f5 let's start with it's a
three move I don't have much time to
think I'm gonna take
then let's play this I want to win d4 I
think I'm gonna win one of these parts
yeah because now that Bishop takes f3
Knight takes d4 and I'm up upon White
has the two bishops but it doesn't
matter because I'm getting a great
position I'm winning another pawn -
alright some momentum going my way
let's bring in the king I guess b5 works
now all the way more stuff just to
connected passers passed pawns must be
pushed okay oh so Gannicus lost a game
so I have still kind of a nice lead by
three points and a streak the Gannicus
just started another game so I have not
played them yet if he berserks that game
he'll tie me play Traxler gambits I'm
not attracts or type of person it's lady
for I played this guy before this guy
has an amazing streak against me he's
it's eight to one lifetime score so I
have to take this seriously I'd see
seven like I saw some video on youtube
like Aronian vs. yasser sara Juan
Aronian played some nights e7 move or
did yasser play 97 someone play tonight
c7 it's interesting idea this queen d3 I
have very least Bishop c2 otherwise I
just want to push my D pawn
yeah and we'll have some iqp position
with an eye on c7 just look to improve
at some point I might take the knight on
c6 get some better structure that's a
good move let's play 94 discouraging
Bishop f6
get the bishop in
hmm
Bishop d2 looks interesting
Oh d2 is probably not a good move
because 93 is massive threats yeah I
don't like my position let's just take
and keep it simple oh that didn't keep
it simple my rook stuck this is so sad
let's play this that's still playable
it's not the most pleasant situation I
might be losing a pawn probably I'm
losing upon a queen g4 maybe or maybe a
a3 looks like the best try okay so d4 is
attacked and 93 is coming so what to do
oh this is so bad
I have one idea I'm gonna play this 93r
up do you want it has a bit concerned
about that I just forgot that Bishop was
hanging that's so bad this is where
fatigue comes into play I'm not going to
resign because miracles do exist this is
really bad what to do maybe I will
resign
I don't know why I have trouble with
this guy he's he's good at chess
I'm gonna try and try and meet in one
I'll probably got mated myself okay I
read sign that was painful I'm still in
first place I think you're still playing
neither of us on a streak do i bezerk
let's beserk let's be aggressive what is
this opening looks passive but also
looks playable okay so we'll have some
position are we trading everything I
want to trade everything the bishop back
okay let's imbalance things a little bit
give white some double pawns but the
rook the rook on seats so my king can
come in and so I can double up we're
gonna trade more okay by winning a pawn
here there's a big c7 Knight g5 guess he
has rook d7 and but I can bring the
knight back to have five that's good
yeah this guy got a little to trade
happy I'm just trying to simplify
everything oh maybe this is still okay I
should still went upon so I can take
okay rook d7 King f6 rook e1 e six
and the goal is to play a five rook c8
rook c7 neutralizes rook he wants to do
this in this I have to allow it
hmm yeah truck t2 would have given me
some larger problems but now it's
looking okay
yeah there okay I'll have much time to
think maybe just King up attack the pawn
and this okay this is looking looking
easier now to convert still takes work
nothing in life is easy
okay this'll be easy now I can win
another pawn defend me six to find out
seven
actually maybe so it's not so easy I
have to still make progress
mmm-hmm let's move up
okay this is what we call building a
bridge okay and now this is what we call
winning
[Music]
I don't know why I'm struggling with
this there you go
dr. tournament 69 points still needs to
get my streak back half hour left so I
have two losses still up a bunch of
rating points I'm not gonna be zurk
let's play some what opening is is going
to be maybe some weird opening it should
be five we'll have some kind of Carlsen
Caruana opening rosolie moe
you know I really don't know too much
about this line but I would assume it's
playable
I already mess up though
I think I've already messed up that's so
bad I can't take on c3 I have to suffer
with this position maybe it's not too
bad those b2 is hanging Knight takes e5
Bishop takes p2
it's a game at some point I might lose a
pawn
apply some pressure
some funny line here I'm gonna go for it
c4 D takes c4 Bishop f5 takes my knight
I take back I went my pawn back and I'm
happy he doesn't take the Knights I
might not win the pawn back
I think I'll still be relatively happy
there's some compensation
maybe this move looks fun
not sure what that does but it just
looks fun
okay 92 does that do anything I feel
like I'm just playing those that aren't
doing anything I could play Queen b6 and
try and win upon maybe Queen b6 other
than c5 it's so complicated let's play
h6 no actually yeah
because if Bishop h4 then Queen b6 and
then I can win the pot if takes and
that's two bishops versus two nights
okay now his C pawns are weak I forgot
about a seven but who cares about a
seven let's play rook aids I'll win the
a pawn back I have 92 let's take on e to
first or let's take on d4 first
and two bishops are strong a four huh
what's the draw isn't that the second
draw fur Bishop e6 is a very sneaky move
the thread is very subtle
there's also alignment against this rook
the rook is tied down to the fang the
pond so I don't think this defends
against the threat the threat was f5 I
mean maybe there's some workaround
now if the light moves I can just take
and then win the rook
and then simplify
mmm let's hold on to everything he wants
another draw I don't want to draw this
is trade and make him resign
kind of annoying that what to do
I'm still in first place
I could report him yeah cuz I think it's
i think there's actual like me chest
etiquette rules that you can't like spam
the draw button but what to do
[Music]
am i using safari oh that that question
was not directed at me but I am using
Safari it's much faster than Chrome I
would prefer to use Chrome but what to
do I guess the only reason I use Chrome
is to block ads well each house has no
ads so good to go this was a slight
waste of time but it's better to look at
it as like a pleasant break break from
the action use opera what's the
advantage of opera is it even faster
than Safari okay so I mean we tick is
catching up
we take Boozer King a bunch of games
I'll have my streak this is gonna be a
close finish and all the players close
behind that's good that we tick is
playing number three guy
okay I'm gonna beserk thanks for the
bits from the ice 71 bits for 71 points
okay we'll have a Budapest
opera has better sound quality but I
have my tab on mutes actually I don't
know if I should have the tab on you or
unmute it let's take first and play 95
try and get the Bishop hair okay now
it's time for some attack oh I got the
pun I was slow on that one
this opera has some musical relevance
can I take on c4 probably not this is
kind of annoying I'm gonna go for this
move the attempt is just to simplify and
attack e3
okay let's take
mmm whites position probably looks a
little bit better but it'll be okay as
long as I manage my time I take and play
Bishop c5 probably not maybe work t6 is
a move the power of the rook lift then
maybe b6 Bishop e7 also defending a5
there's some line like Bishop f3 rookie
7 Bishop e3 I have to play c5 I think
it's ok looks weird as long as I'm not
losing anything
oh maybe I have six always playoff six
undermines the battery ah never playoff
six I forgot the saying my rooks
probably gonna get trapped oh this is so
bad but maybe I can take on e4 if he
plays g3 yeah okay some compensation to
bishops positions opening up Bishop c5
on the horizon there should be seven
it's like a Danish gambit actually is
this this is winning
after a bishop b7 thinking maybe he had
to play like Queen after three is how
does he defend he can't defend both g2
an each one which means his King has to
go for a walk but then Bishop before in
it's game over
and we took has passed me it's
unfortunate but he probably deserves it
looking for the quickest ways to meet so
it's like one possibility
now let's do this and take upon
I'm just trying to made in the quickest
way possible
looking at Bishop to b5 and then
probably queen e7 and c6
that's not meat it's annoying
well probably the quickest way to win is
just by flagging
okay so I have time for a few more games
behind by three points I'm I apologize
if there's any lag if there's lag I'm
sorry that was just the same same
sentence it's been long a long stream
okay this is actually an important game
for my my livelihood like the winner of
this game probably wins the tournament
he's playing like this I think be six
whatever line and we'll see what he does
let's play 92 okay so he's playing this
line it's playable
alright this line I thought it was just
bad for black but if you speed me 9 to 1
maybe there's something I'm forgetting
about we have the same rating or both
2377 that's strange
so a lot riding on this game
this is like the very first video in my
London opening course like this exact
game so far it's on YouTube it's a chess
youtube channel I think the move is to
play this first there's a trick if fish'
takes off - King takes
oh he's falling into it because I have
c6 in mind and life is good maybe it
still takes a little bit of work but
this is really good for lights Madball
stare thanks for the sub long time no
sub
this is why I like the London lines like
this are quite nice
I think rook rook move should be
sufficient
you can probably just take on d5 and win
the pond unless there's something better
now this should be good enough the
problem is that there's back ranked mate
problems like rook c8 rook takes d5 he
can't take on c6 if there should be five
I have 94 light is useful in many lines
compasses the threats imagining Bishop
c4 c7 just wins a game probably 94 rook
d7 coming soon
taking my time here cuz he's uh he's in
first place okay I kissed past me too
though let's play King here let's play
uh probably before soon he wants to take
so let's play this okay
he resigns so I'm back in the lead
I was my second time ever beating we
take he just fell for opening
preparation like it was all prepared
through through c6 and it's shared with
everyone it's on YouTube okay so I'm
ahead by one points probably time for
one or two more games I'm gonna play a
offbeat line with a three very tricky
move order and idea is to encourage them
to have some passive position and ninety
five might be too early because f4 will
come soon got for Bishop at three let's
start with h3 controlling g4 then f4
I'll avoid trades because I have more
space
once the sack all of them sack
let's just complete development
no I didn't mean to trade so soon
but that's okay guess I was just
expecting a four
yeah see five is playable it's a little
bit weakening but yeah it is playable
when I go for this night manoeuvre and
maybe g5 at some points like g5 9895
let's have some initiative
oh and then 96 so I'm threatening to win
material so that's a decent move still
play g5 if Queen takes a Sri I have
Bishop g2 I win the night it's 98 I
probably play king h2 and then later go
for 95 or maybe Bishop g4 probably king
h2 he wants to play 96 at some points
I want to play queen g2 and just start
attacking
forgot about the fork okay well that's
not good
cuz now I'm objectively worse but I
still have some attack thinking about
these types of maneuvers yeah let's try
and keep things closed he's writing this
so I'll play that this yeah it doesn't
feel like I'm down material which is
usually a good sign I'm still gonna have
initiative problem is I don't think
there'll be time for another game after
this one
so the first priority is winning this
game
some crazy line where I just maybe I
play this first ideas of g6 she plays g6
Ivan at age six if that I think this is
just crushing because I went out seven
and in this line at Fischer g7 IV five
obstructing the Queen from defending the
bishop so you could take on c2 I have to
take back so maybe I'll try and sneak in
one more quick win this is gonna be
really close get five points for winning
this would be nice if he just resigns
there we go okay so Gannicus basically
needs to win in the next three minutes
to get first place yeah I'm not even
gonna be zerk because if I win it's
enough time but I'm gonna try and I
played this guy before we're going into
the same line maybe he'll do something
differently the goal is to win quickly
with this time he plays a3 a3 loses a
tempo because I want to play a5 anyway
94 interesting so he's playing a
different line let's play d6 open up
this Bishop this work could lead to
something if Bishop takes e5 Bishop
takes you to I could have some meat
coming up like this type of thing maybe
I should take your first and then take
with the rook
it's kind of annoying I'm just Queenie
for have any purpose let's play Queenie
for avoiding Queen f3 Queen G to just
put everything in the center and I'm not
gonna win this game in one more minute
okay Anna kiss is winning but his
opponent just needs to survive for one
more minute
okay now the plan is this in this yeah
point out three rook f5 Queen g2 Queen
h6 Wow
interesting move
yeah at this point I just can't allow
Gannicus - I can't stop Gannicus there's
13 seconds left in the tournament I've
never been so serious about winning a
tournament Hey tournament is over I
think I won but the game still continues
until it's over so let's try and finish
cleanly maybe I'll play g6g 6 h 5 King
g7 I'll put the rook here mmm that was a
good move I have to put the rook here
I'll bring the bishop back to ethics
nope III could be hanging
that's a good move I have to go back I
have a queen side majority so I might
end up like pushing b5 try and make a
pass pawn usually Queen and Knight are
better than Queen and Bishop but if I
have an outside passer could change the
story wants to play 93 he wants to stop
it for you I can play Bishop a3 then
check
the bishop on f6 93 can't be played
because Queen takes b3
so we attack so fun let's defend an
attack
probably a four and then just get the
pawn to a three and be happy I'm Knight
c4 though and I'd see for Queen c5 queen
c3 mg8
actually Queen c3 I might have a Bishop
f6 because e5 I just take on e5 actually
this might just be an easy win because
Bishop f6 a5 Bishop takes e5 like pawn
Queens otherwise of the Queen moves I
just push
yeah I assume 8 - oh wait no 82 is a
blunder
the Queen would still defend maybe it's
not so simple
yes I have to move back and I'll
probably play King G it yeah when I play
like Queen c3 King g8 than a choose of
threats
put the Queen here talking the pawn
preparing queen bee to defending the
diagonal to my king
throw in a check and then play Queen me
- going for a -
okay so now I just probably take the
Knights and then make a queen it still
takes work to win this but time is on my
side probably go after the f2 pawn
actually after you can't be defended I
guess you can play off 3 4 then Queen d4
and some kind of maid is coming I would
think that's a tricky move looking for a
mate
check let's start with this and then
play this I don't think I want to trade
this just yet I'd like to get some looks
one position let's do this
wait let's do this
yeah I should probably just trade down
make life a bit easier or just flag him
die miss mate
each one was usually defended by the
Queen
okay finally ah some long fights
I'm sure earlier there is I think
actually earlier I missed some chances
to just take some free pawns like people
pointing out in the chat I miss b3 I
think I missed a three at some points
it's not the most high-quality game but
thanks guys for watching is there anyone
who watched like the whole tournament
I'd be impressive yeah I started
streaming a long time ago it's it's
after 8 now I'm probably gonna end it
here because let's go back to tournament
enjoy the confetti
so Gannicus I guess did not win in time
yeah I'm gonna look for food before
places close i do appreciate all the
viewers and i would highly encourage
people to watch the world championship
tomorrow
joanna tries in the chat thanks your
honor for watching do you just join also
I feel like I missed a lot of like
questions and comments earlier that
people were asking other things for the
bits ricardo butters so i think here's
what I'll do I'm gonna end it here for
the YouTube audience so YouTube people
if you're watching this in the future